there was there were some updates in the
veritas stuff i think the court ordered
the new york times to stop publishing
their privileged communications yeah and
the new york times said no
and then i think the judge responded
with excuse me like
i i was so this is this is a really big
part of the whole defamation process
what's happening with veritas and like
the defamation as a whole
that
the new york times is being sued by
veritas
they
are given access to veritas's privileged
legal communications which basically
just interfered entirely with the courts
process with veritas's process and they
did it with a smile on their faces i
have to imagine when the judge found out
he was probably like yo you're spitting
on me now like i gotta deal with this
stuff and you have access to their you
know what's gonna happen if if i rule on
this veritas is gonna file so many
complaints that i'm gonna get
overwhelmed on everything i mean what
are your guys's thoughts on how the
judge would react to someone again
they're you know
i mean i i had not heard about the
privileged communication thing how how
did they do you know how they got asked
it is it is believed the fbi oh okay so
sorry i did hear about that i did hear
about that my my mistake yeah um
i gotta imagine the judge was like
fuming there there are very limited
circumstances in which a judge can put a
prior restraint on on speech of a party
um and and you know this would be one of
those sort of situations look you got
access however you got it to their
privileged attorney-client
communications you should never have
seen that that stuff uh should be
privileged from everybody including the
fbi and so now no you can't go out and
and start publishing it it's not press
worthy it's not newsworthy you're just
trying to gain an advantage over your
lawsuit opponent that's the time that
this should happen um if they keep it up
you know the judge hopefully will resort
to sanctions and heavy sanctions yeah i
mean look judges uh you know the one
whether they're appointed by a
republican a democrat or liberty
whatever it doesn't matter the one thing
they hate more than anything is getting
reversed it doesn't matter at what level
or state federal county local appeals
court they hate being told i got it
wrong and what this guy's doing is if i
have to rule on this like you said tim
he's going to issue all these rulings
and then they're going to contest them
and he's afraid that they might actually
some crazy appeals court might actually
come down and say actually legal
privilege communications in this
instance are okay for whatever mickey
mouse reason that the media trumpeted so
i think he's playing it pretty pretty
good and pretty safe and that he's
probably avoiding trying to issue an
actual ruling that can be appealed but
he's trying to get the lawyers to get in
line with the fbi and support the
privileged communication
and we we saw this uh with the written
house case right bru uh judge schroeder
he was so hesitant to issue a definitive
ruling on anything even on the
evidentiary issues pre-trial he says
i'm going to
uh i'm going to
hold off on this with a with a
predisposition towards keeping them out
it's like that's that's not a ruling
just just say this can't come in or this
can come in and then you can you can
change your mind later you're a judge
you can do that but i think i think a
lot of us are happy with some of the
rulings from the judge in the written
house case but his inability to issue a
ruling on the fake evidence admitted by
the prosecution has resulted in uh i see
it this is what antifa is putting out in
in spades
they're they're posting
news clips that say prosecutors showed
video they say is of kyle rittenhouse
pointing a gun at activists
that's it
and now they're saying now all the
antifa is going kyle rittenhouse was
waving a gun around threatening people
and when they tried to stop him he
killed him and the judge let him get
away with it
the judge if he if he had a stronger
spine i'll say he has some of the spine
because he did dismiss the gun charge he
did do some rulings he could have said
that's a computer generated image out
sorry
let me know what you think because my
argument was the defense had no idea how
to explain that the prosecution admitted
cgi evidence my my thought process was
the defense should have asked the expert
when was the image file
created and he would have said last week
so this image file was not created on
august 25th 2020 no it was not your
honor this image is not from the night
in question i will it be you know
admissible or something
that that's one way to go about it the
other way is simple
they had tons of evidentiary issues in
this case um normally you have to have
someone who will testify that the thing
that you're looking at is a fair and
accurate representation of the thing
that happened and the only guy they had
testify about this footage was a
detective who looked at it on his iphone
and when you really factor in the fact
that a capital murder case the entire
theory of the prosecution got blown out
in the first half that's why this
footage came in and they had to change
their entire strategy and in a kid's
life in a capital murder case hangs on
the idea that a detective who was not
present that night
pinched to zoom on an iphone and thinks
he saw something that he can't replicate
because he didn't record that pinch to
zoom there's no way for the defense to
look at it challenge the authenticity of
it say that there's interpolation adding
pixels um they they tried sort of to
ham-fist their way into that argument uh
but
but at the end of the day what they
needed to do was just say your honor
there's no way anybody here can testify
that the picture we're seeing now is a
fair and accurate representation
it worked
the uh i i you know i gotta be as i
don't know if the prosecution actually
cared about the end results that's going
to imp the cultural impact but then you
get people posting these things the
black lives matter supporters saying
written house was pointing a gun
then you get people believing the latest
attack was a retaliation
so let's throw we'll bring it back to
this veritas thing you you mentioned
this judge uh he's not like he basically
is not really tr wanting to rule on the
fact that the new york times has access
to their legal documents which in my
opinion
i don't know how they can continue the
court proceedings
at that point
so that the judge seems to be doing
nothing is that the gist of it uh i i
don't know what the judge has said about
it um i've just heard about the uh the
disclosure by the allegedly by the fbi
right to project veritas's enemies with
that being said i mean if the judge is
not issuing a gag order on some of this
stuff then he's hesitant to try and
restrain the press and i think at this
point he well he did uh the judge said
stop publishing sure uh veritas's
privileged communications the new york
times said no
we have a first amendment right to
report the news
and we have a story right here it's from
uh today actually new york times urges
no prior restraint against veritas
coverage
uh basically saying veritas's claims do
not implicate the kind of extraordinary
public harms national security that
american courts have suggested okay blah
blah blah i don't care about the
argument here let's get a little bit
hypothetical then my question is
you've got
person a suing person b
person b illegally obtains person a's
communications with their lawyer as it
pertains to this lawsuit
how could a judge issue how could a
judge handle that case i mean he's got
to throw it out it's just it's straight
up privilege but here's the thing right
there's unfortunately it's happened
before when bob mueller's u.s attorney
massachusetts he actually had a criminal
case where he uh surveilled a client and
their attorney's conversation and
utilized it and the prosecution came
back to bite him in the butt uh in one
of the biggest narco-trafficking cases
out of florida same thing the u.s
attorney's office obtained the
communications between the defendant and
his lawyer and didn't disclose it now in
those criminal cases it's a little
different right there's a harsher
penalty because due process is at stake
but the rule of law is the same it's a
privileged communication all you need to
ask new york times is if they're okay
with this then what project veritas
should do is be like fine give us all of
new york times privileged communications
oh and the judge could be like yes and
release it to the general public and
make everyone see it i mean that's what
the new york times is doing right now
yeah go ahead then we just see all the
emails where they're like don't cover
epstein yeah yeah yeah it's like oh yeah
yeah that story we gotta we gotta make
sure it doesn't go anywhere just like of
course cbs news like which project
veritas exposed was hiding a huge expose
which they had according to one of their
reporters they had i think i'm joking
clinton and other presidents so again
they were covering that story but vanity
fair had a very interesting take on this
because again it's all about framing and
the way that these people just frame
stuff is just so disingenuous they had
an article that was titled press freedom
advocates alarmed that project veritas
just muzzled the new york times that's
their understanding of the situation and
again it's it's it's it's so
mind-boggling to see this kind of like
twisting and turning insulation of basic
facts to push a narrative and an agenda
here's the only good thing that comes to
this if like you were saying earlier you
know lawyers are expensive these suits
are expensive but when you bring them
and they're credible they take one to
two years
at the end of it you actually get some
really good rulings on what we call case
law precedent if these cases survive but
what these guys try to do is drown them
out like veritas isn't going anywhere
right right these guys are actually if i
was at times lawyers i'd be like you
need to sit down and shut up because we
might squeak out of this case but you
are going to mess up the future of
defamation for defendants if you keep
down this track because the judge will
force he can't he might not issue now or
in a month or six months but in a year
he's going to have to make some rulings
and those rulings will likely get
appealed and then affirmed its law are
judges obligated to uh
stick to case law like if someone says
in the case of supposed to theoretically
yeah
they're they're uh they're they're
supposed to call follow binding
authority and the idea is that uh
they'll get reversed and as cash said
earlier uh if they get reversed that's
the worst thing a judge wants to do um
there's not much practical effect for
lifetime federal judges but new york
state judges aren't lifetime appointees
um and and so there there are there
could be real effects for for them but
imagine just just rolling it back if
this stands if what new york times is
doing stands what's to stop any news
publication whoever gets sued from just
illegally obtaining the privileged
communications of their of their
opponents and and publishing and shaming
them that's why this judge has to go
ahead and issue the order and if if new
york times doesn't like it take it to
the supreme court go ahead appeal it up
to the to the new york court of appeals
and then appeal it to the united states
supreme court call it a first amendment
issue freedom of the press if you want
and let them determine it because then
uh you know if we get that case on the
books okay fine but at the end of the
day uh judges do have some limited
ability to issue a gag order when there
is sufficient justification and i can't
imagine how illegally obtaining your
opponent's privileged communications and
then trying to publish those privileged
communications to shame them would not
meet me maybe i'll get my lawyer in my
defamation case against the times to
file for the times is
uh privileged communications and then
send them out and what's the times argue
gonna be they're gonna be like uh well
we previously arguments like this right
like here's an article from new york
times no i have to i have to imagine
that when it comes to losing in court
it's when you directly try to affect the
judge's powers and their ability to do
their job so it's like you know you go
in front of judge a judge and you're
like this guy kicked my dog and the
other guy is like i didn't kick his dog
and it's like here's a video i'm kicking
my dog he owes me 100 bucks the judge is
like i am involved in this
uh i think the evidence stands and the
judge you know the issue of ruling or
however it goes um
what happens when you have someone
saying your honor i'm going to attempt
to directly interfere with your ability
to rule on this because screw you i
should be allowed to do it i feel like
that's the fastest way to lose there's
just no world that i can imagine being
in and i've be appeared in court
probably 3 000 times that if i ever said
that to a state court judge or a federal
judge the federal court judge would
probably lock me up for contempt of
court for being so arrogant remember
when christ he'd just be like what or
she didn't kraus talk back like several
times in the written house trial which
is insane to me because like don't get
brazen with me i know i'm pretty i'm
pretty sure i was watching you guys when
you guys were like oh whoa like don't
talk back to a judge are you nuts yeah
big court's a little different i mean
you know this is the one we talked about
a couple weeks ago the reason we get
such a wide berth in the written house
case state courts allow cameras no
federal report in america allows a
camera which is why you get those
cartoon caricatures so state court
almost becomes movie-like so there's a
little more freedom i mean you're not
supposed to talk back against the judge
period i never did that um but there's a
little more freedom because they also
get like a little i mean this guy's like
one of the most famous judges in america
right now
oh yeah yeah
these these guys first of all they're
lawyers so they have egos going in
second of all they're given a robe that
tells them they get to decide the fate
of lives
every single day and that their
decisions have the force of government
behind them so you can imagine like just
the audacity of telling the government
no and the government having a
mouthpiece with a with a human ego
behind it to say no yes i mean so so
basically the new york times gets a hold
of veritas's lawyer communications about
how they operate what they're doing
while they're being sued by veritas
which directly impacts their their their
the lawsuit and the judge said stop
publishing this stuff
and new york times said shut up judge i
can't i have to imagine it's like this
is
sanction them sanction them and let them
take it to the let them take it to the
supreme court maybe they win what would
that happen well this is also on the
heels on the fbi rating james o'keefe
and his employees
apartments taking their cell phones away
from them because and cash when you said
i want my lawyers to do this i was going
to recommend you also get an
intelligence agency to go after your
enemy and bust down their doors and take
away their cell phones and take their
communications that way and then you
could release it to the general public
without even involving the job so in the
other instance actually i think my
friend harmeet was representing james
o'keefe in vegeta's case she actually
got that judge to issue a ruling and and
stand down the communications going over
that's the right way to do it that's
what this judge should be doing but
didn't he do that i thought i thought
harmeet posted this yeah the judge on
that first ruling i'm saying right right
right privileged communication oh it
should be the same exact thing like
there's there's not really a difference
there in terms of the law like you can't
one you don't have access to that
information two you can't be putting it
out if you don't have lawful access to
it in the first place and there's no
difference evil people
you know because it's like we can agree
to disagree on a lot of things but when
you're like your fundamental rights
are void because i'm a journalist i'm
like nah you're just evil like the idea
that okay so when it comes to the united
states comes the constitution comes to
what we believe other people are
afforded they're afforded their legal
defense the right to due process
if you think we have a first amendment
right to take away your right to due
process i'm like nah it doesn't work
that way that would be like someone i
have a right to guns so i'm going to rob
people no it doesn't work that way yeah
basically what they're doing
yeah
i i agree it's it's uh and it's it's the
arrogance and i would say the death
rattle of a lot of major media companies
we've seen we've seen competition
growing i mean heck this show is
competition for mainstream media they
know it they know about independent
media and and how it's been changing the
landscape over the past really uh decade
or more and and they're now lashing out
and that's why that's why they hate
veritas right because veritas is started
by a guy who goes out and does the
things that media used to do
and they can't control the narrative
they can't stop someone like project
verdus they can they can give them a
roadblock here or there but they can't
do it uh and and the more independent
voices that come out the more we're
gonna see this sort of uh retaliation
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you